paul ronzheimer bei uns ja das ganze mit
uns verfolgt hat für den liegt dieses
papier die wichtigsten ergebnisse paul
daraus für dich für mich war das ein nix
ist klar ein aufschieben gipfel ein
chaos gipfel am ende denn wenn wir uns
anschauen was dort beschlossen ist dann
weiß ich heute nicht genau was ich jetzt
darf was ich nicht darf wann gilt
welcher grenzwert welcher incidents
werden also die kanzlerin hat klar
gesagt sie wollte mehr sie konnte sich
nicht durchsetzen und gleichzeitig haben
die anderen ministerpräsidenten und
regierungspolitiker ja bereits
angekündigt dass auch sie glauben das
waren mehr braucht denn ansonsten müsste
man ja nicht sagen dass man am 19
dezember wieder was macht also eine
salamitaktik die dort angewendet wird
und das ist glaube ich frustrierend für
die menschen denn sie bekommen keine
klare ansage woche um auch immer
wahrscheinlich weil es ein
regierungschaos gibt zwischen ampel
zwischen der noch bestehenden zwischen
den ministerpräsidenten aber die worte
die gewählt worden die dramatik die dort
angestimmt wurde insbesondere von der
kanzlerin aber auch anderen passt nicht
zu diesen unklaren aussagen also zwei
geht zum beispiel ein thema ja da gilt
dann ein grenzwert bei der
hospitalisierung keiner weiß dann genau
wann ist 2 gewann 2 g plus was ist mit
der situation in den krankenhäusern dann
tatsächlich also wann darf ich bei 3g
was wie wo also ich glaube viele leute
sind einfach durcheinander danach und
noch eine sache ich finde das wichtigste
thema haben sie in dieser
pressekonferenz gar nicht angesprochen
wo war denn das impfen mein gott wo war
die klare ansage dass wir jetzt an jeder
straßenecke impfen da war gar nichts da
kam nichts und das war viel zu wenig und
das war enttäuschend dass bei diesem
wichtigen thema ostern wurde darüber
gesprochen im internen kreis aber in der
pressekonferenz gesagt bitte bitte
lassen sich impfen aber nicht wir zahlen
ihnen 100 euro wir machen dies wir
machen jenes nichts